all i know is this once i was blind and
now i see this is the text that appears
on screen at the end of raging bull
one of scorsese's most critically
acclaimed films raging bull is the story
of boxer jake lamotta an angry
an abusive man whose behavior alienates
him from the people around him the
choice to leave the audience with these
lines from the christian bible is at
first glance a puzzling one omada has no
conversion experience the film contains
religious imagery but lamada never once
goes near a church and there's almost no
talk of god or anything religious in the
film it's a story about a man who
behaves badly and whose life
disintegrates around him so why does
scorsese choose to end the film with a
verse from scripture about redemption
this video is sponsored by mubi
but christ did not die for the good and
beautiful
that is easy enough
the hard thing is to die
for the miserable and corrupt
the wolf of wall street spends an
extended sequence focused on a
debaucherous escapade in which jordan
belfort accidentally overdoses on
quaaludes
to pretty hilarious effect
this happens to be one of the milder of
the film's depictions of the profane or
the behaviors of humans that we
typically consider to run counter to the
virtues and values taught by religion
three years after this scene scorsese
would say he was making his next film
silent to get to know jesus better and
as i prepare to do his work i see his
face before me i'm talking about
this few directors have devoted as much
screen time to violent despicable
profane characters as martin scorsese
from taxi drivers travis bickle to henry
hill and goodfellas wolf of wall
street's jordan belfort or the
irishman's frank sheeran scorsese's best
known films are ones that showcase
characters who are remorselessly violent
corrupt self-seeking abusive or who
continually betray the people around
them
and yet in 2016 with his film silence
scorsese made one of the most thoughtful
sincere explorations of christian faith
in the last decade with the pope saying
he hopes it bears good fruit so you
might think with silence that scorsese
was turning from his old profane ways
back to religion but silence was far
from the first time scorsese made a film
explicitly exploring spiritual subject
matter
forgive them
[Music]
the last temptation of christ in 1988
directly explored the life of jesus and
11 years after that scorsese told the
story of the dalai lama in kundu while
these three explicitly spiritual films
have never been his most popular work i
think understanding the themes at their
core and the role christianity has
played in scorsese's own life is crucial
to understanding central themes that are
present in all of his films and the
perspective from which he approaches
even his most profane characters and
stories
as far back as i can remember i always
wanted to be a gangster
in goodfellas henry hill has no
aspirations of being a saint he ventures
into a life of violence drugs and
corruption he's going to be working
together not hesitantly but joyfully
he wears a cross but this seems to be at
best a symbolic nod to the divine no
element of his life seems to reflect the
virtue and self-sacrifice it represents
this life of crime does eventually catch
up with him and we find henry's life the
one we've just seen play out in the film
under scrutiny in a courtroom in this
moment we see the central religious
theme that is present in almost all
scorsese's films judgment and redemption
for a long period of time i was
fascinated by
stories of the missionaries scorsese was
raised catholic
when i was about eight or nine ten years
old
and i wanted to become a marine
missionary obviously we now know that he
would eventually abandon those hopes and
be drawn into cinema
lord
i'm not worthy to eat your flesh
not worthy to drink your blood not
worthy to drink your blood scorsese's
third feature but the most well-known of
his early films mean streets follows the
character of charlie in the streets of
new york charlie is a low-level criminal
but charlie is also obsessed with his
spiritual status he has a strong sense
that he will be judged for his sins
that's all [ __ ] except the pain
right
the pain of hell
the bird from a ladder match increased a
million times on the streets charlie
acts out the role of a priest he
jokingly quotes scripture let me ask you
something i doubt the king of jews
does not say this to thyself or have
others talk to me and gives out
blessings
but more symbolically he also tries to
act as a mediator between johnny a
lowlife who is constantly racking up
debts and his other friend michael who
is constantly asking for those debts to
be repaid don't you think you ought to
care a little more about johnny's
payments to me i think you should you
know
michael michael nobody's out to screw
you
i guarantee that johnny owes a debt to
michael and if this debt isn't repaid
the result will be violent judgment this
is a street-level reflection of the
spiritual position that charlie finds
himself in within the structure of the
church he owes a debt to god for his
sins and if he cannot repay that debt
the result will be violence in hell like
charlie between johnny and michael the
church and priests act as a mediator
between charlie taking confessions for
his sins and the judgment of god but
while charlie confesses he refuses to do
what the priest tells him to do now that
may be okay for the others but it just
doesn't work for me
i mean if i do something wrong i just
want to pay for it my way
so i do my own penance for my own sins
what do you say huh
besides i don't like little crates i
tell you you're not supposed to like it
johnny is also indignant and refuses to
do the work required to pay off his
debts and when a michael comes knocking
charlie like a priest or perhaps even as
a symbol of christ himself attempts to
negotiate on johnny's behalf for those
deaths to be forgiven from the church's
perspective charlie is like johnny he
refuses to do the work necessary to pay
his moral debts ultimately despite
charlie's attempts he is unable to delay
michael's judgment forever
if for johnny who doesn't do what his
priest charlie tells him to do judgment
on the streets comes calling will
eternal judgment come calling for
charlie who also refuses to do what his
priest tells him to do the film's ending
implies a question
what is required to be forgiven i'm
trying to what i'm trying mean streets
has a lot of autobiographical elements
and i think we see reflected in the film
scorsese's own grappling with his
movement away from the calling of the
church and towards the more profane
world of the streets we know now that
while scorsese would eventually consider
himself elapsed catholic his concern for
his spiritual status would never leave
him
is the film blasphemy or an affirmation
of faith we were just wondering what
wrong you feel the hollywood's committed
by making this film they've offended
millions of christians all over the
world many of the protesters threatening
the front of the opera house while those
with tickets would ignore the advice of
the bishop of cork not to attend queued
for admission we're very indignant that
they would come up with such a profane
well what's profane about it i haven't
seen have you seen the movie well it's
uh why are you picking this movie here
because i think it's disgraceful what
they're trying to do to our lord the
last temptation of christ was not well
received by religious groups or
institutions one group in france even
going so far as to torch a theater where
it was being screened scorsese's own
catholic church declared it morally
offensive the controversy centered
around this scorsese and writer paul
schrader a protestant calvinist wanted
to use the life of christ as a metaphor
for exploring a human struggle between
the sacred and the profane the crux of
the story is that jesus rather than
being coolly confident in his position
as fully god as he is in most depictions
struggles deeply as someone who is fully
man with his divinity how could
i be the messiah
when those people were torturing
magdalen i wanted to kill them
and then i opened my mouth
and now comes the word love why i don't
understand and on the cross faces a last
temptation of stepping down and being
just a man the focus on christ as fully
man makes the struggle of christ very
relatable but for the religious who have
a deep veneration for the image of
christ the extent to which scorsese
visualized christ's temptation was an
impossible pill to swallow anybody who
mocks the crucifixion will burn in hell
the fact that many religious groups
found reason to be offended is not
surprising the film itself is a direct
attack on biblical orthodox christianity
what is perhaps more surprising is the
level of sincerity with which scorsese
himself was approaching the film looking
past how the film was received by
religious groups the last temptation of
christ was not on scorsese's part an
attempt to denigrate or critique christ
as god but actually an attempt to try to
better understand the figure of christ
faith and religion leading up to and
following its release corsasi defended
the film's spiritual value but years
later in the director's commentary for
the criterion edition he would make some
interesting comments about its success
in exploring these themes in this
particular film by directing this
picture dealing with the iconography
head-on and dealing with the themes
head-on
may not have been as successful as
dealing with those themes in mean
streets and raging bull where time
places it in a different context but
it's still the same theme you see that
scorsese sees mean streets and raging
bull as ultimately more successful
explorations of the same spiritual ideas
reveals just how significant the
spiritual core of those films are
charlie's struggle in mean streets and
christ's struggle in the last temptation
are essentially the same both grapple
with a divine calling and the allure of
the profane world just as scorsese
himself did in the last temptation
scorsese attempted to bring humanity and
the profane reality of the streets he
grew up on into the religious story of
christ in mean streets scorsese brings
the religious story of christ into the
profanity of the streets we don't make
religion something that's foreign
that's separate from life
that's the key
like it says in galatians 3
have you suffered so many things in vain
kate fear gives us yet another of
scorsese's moral quandaries sam boden a
defense attorney intentionally botches a
defense in order to let his client
receive a harsher sentence i mean why me
i was your lawyer i defended you a
result he believed and we the audience
don't have much difficulty believing was
completely justified 14 years later his
client max katy is released from prison
and returns seeing himself as enacting
god's judgment on his lawyer for not
fulfilling his duty to defend his client
i am like god and god like me it's an
over-the-top complicated and kind of
difficult movie to watch but there's an
important moment towards the end that i
want to highlight katie invokes a sort
of makeshift courtroom
i'm sorry your honor i agree that was
argument and when he looks towards the
judge he looks towards the sky as if
he's looking to god i can't ask these
questions your honor he is a hostile
witness and he also looks directly at us
i think this gives us a clue to how
scorsese is wanting his audience to
approach his films katie is asking god
to act as a judge and scorsese is asking
us to act as a jury didn't mean anything
when i was broke i would go out and rob
some more
we ran everything
we paid off cops we paid off lawyers we
paid off judges it's not the only
scorsese film to end in a courtroom the
end of goodfellas recontextualizes the
entire film as a confession we're the
jury hearing henry hill's testimony and
now we must come up with a verdict this
maneuver of asking the audience to act
as a judge or jury is most explicit in
these films but it's implied in almost
every one of scorsese's movies travis
bickle commits a viciously violent act
that he's ultimately praised for by the
media but the audience knows his
internal motivation and has to judge him
for themselves in the departed which is
about an undercover cop we're asked to
wonder how are you judged when from the
outside you look like one of the bad
guys at the end of the wolf of wall
street a film that also acts as a kind
of confession scorsese asks us to judge
jordan belfort for his actions and then
ask us to judge ourselves for
participating in the veneration of his
escapades as entertainment in the
irishman the silent watching eyes of
frank's daughter peggy act as a judging
watchful gaze and in raging bull these
few lines from scripture
recontextualizes the film as a question
about whether jake lamotta can be
redeemed somehow he seems to come to
some sort of peace with himself
he seems to forgive himself and maybe
that's where we have to begin
on that day the faithful received fresh
hope
and i was renewed
it would take an entire video on its own
to unravel all the theological and
spiritual themes in silence so i'm just
going to focus on the elements that help
us better understand these broader
themes of redemption judgment and
forgiveness that run through most of his
films in silence jesuit priests go to
japan in search of another missionary
who is rumored to be an apostate someone
who has given up the faith in japan they
must operate in secret and the japanese
government goes to great lengths to shut
down any foothold christianity might be
gaining in the country but the element
of the story that scorsese is most
interested in and focused on is the act
of apostasy itself
of denying christ symbolically by
stepping on the fumier an image of
christ
and whether this act can be forgiven
kichijiro repeatedly denies christ and
betrays the priests but rodriguez always
mediates on his behalf offering
forgiveness but when rodriguez himself
denies christ is there anyone to offer
him forgiveness an examination of
whether priests stepping on an image of
christ can maintain their faith might
seem disconnected from the depiction of
the debauchery of jordan belfort or a
depiction of the unrelenting betrayal of
frank sheeran but i think scorsese has
the same goal in examining both these
subjects scorsese paints his wrongdoers
with a heavy brush he doesn't give the
audience a comfortable remove from his
character's violence hatred betrayal or
corruption the profane is often
portrayed along with a sense of allure
that allows us to see what drew these
characters into that life in the first
place but attached to all of it is a
question by asking us to act as a judge
scorsese is asking us to consider
whether these characters can be forgiven
and redeemed a question that seems to
haunt not just these films but scorsese
himself do they deserve mercy too and if
they harm so many people
you know well christian idea they do how
do you do that
i i find it hard
you know
we all do
but this is where christ is pushing us
say
maddening but it's it's uh it's a
challenge and it's
it's the right way i think
[Music]
scorsese provokes us to consider the
question more deeply by focusing on the
gray areas where our personal moral
standards come into conflict with the
standard of the law or the church in the
eyes of the justice system max katie is
technically right a defense lawyer is
legally obligated to defend their client
but what is his moral obligation
in our eyes and goodfellas henry hill is
technically redeemed in the eyes of the
law and placed in witness protection but
is he morally redeemed in our eyes and
silence portrays what is technically
within the eyes of the church one of the
worst wrongs someone can perform an
outward denial of christ himself and
then it asks the question will even that
wrong be forgiven looking at these
themes as they sprawl out across his
work we can see scorsese's own struggle
with these ideas play out can i live up
to it i don't know honestly don't think
so but what you do is you keep trying
just keep trying but whatever answers
he's come to on his own ultimately with
his films he simply asks the questions
and leaves the answers to us in silence
we find a priest who does not appear to
be a christian on the outside performing
none of the actions or rights associated
with christianity but who supposedly
holds a remorse and a faith in his heart
and were asked is this enough can he be
redeemed in the irishman we see the
opposite one of scorsese's profane
gangsters who at the end of his life
performs the external rights god we come
before you
sinful and sorrowful
sinful and sorrowful he says the right
words but internally he seems to have no
remorse or true repentance and were
asked is this enough what is required
to be redeemed
in america martin scorsese has been one
of the loudest voices for international
cinema i share that love and one of the
best places i've found to expose myself
to more movies from around the world is
my sponsor for today's video movie movie
is an online streaming cinema with a
focus on discovery and curation i just
started delving into the movies of
indian filmmaker sachajit rai and mubi
just recently added four of his films to
their library that i haven't seen and i
can't wait to check them out i also
recently watched the documentary the
hottest august which follows in the
footsteps of some of my favorite
documentarians like chris marker i
really enjoyed it and i hadn't even
heard of it until i found it on mubi
every day they add a new title to their
huge library of international indie art
house and classic films and you can get
30 days of access for free by using my
link mubi is a great place to discover
something new so i definitely recommend
giving it a try go to mubi.com
thomasflight.mubi.com
thomasflight click the link on the
screen or in the description to get your
30-day extended free trial of mubi
[Music]
there was a lot i wanted to examine
about silence that just wasn't relevant
to this video or didn't have time to get
into but i'm going to make a bonus video
for my five dollar and up patrons this
month so if you want to get access to
that become a patron by going to
patreon.com
thomasflight